Alysa Milano Alissa Milano very
excitable
left-wing figure and actress she just
took to Twitter to beg her many
followers for money for her kids
baseball team tweets out a gofund me my
son's baseball team is raising money for
their Cooper Town trip you know Baseball
Hall of Fame any amount would be so
greatly appreciated you can read more
about the team and make a donation here
okay got got almost 12 million
views it's a bad look it's a bad look
because Alyssa Milano is really really
rich unless she's completely mishandled
her money Alysa Milano has made millions
and millions prob tens of millions of
dollars over the course of her life and
she doesn't need to be begging her
followers to chip in a penny this not a
good look this is annoying when people
do this around the office you know it's
luckily no one does it here cuz the
average age at this company is like 12
but you know I remember this what
happened my mother's office as a kid I
all around the schools say hey sell
wrapping paper or hey sell this thing or
that thing to raise money for a field
trip and then you give it to your
parents and your parents go around the
office and they say h would you mind
donating my school's my kids school
thing and it just it never ends okay
what's bad enough when it's just a
regular middle class person in an office
Alyssa Milano is a very famous very
wealthy Hollywood celebrity not a good
look very famous very wealthy Hollywood
celebrities should be donating not just
to their kids baseball teams but to
other to other um Charities as well I
don't know what her charitable giving
looks like but it's really bad for
wealthy powerful people to be spending
around gofundmes it represents a
fundamental shift in our
country where to quote John Kennedy
people no longer ask what they can do
for their country instead they ask what
their country can do for them they they
treat their country Ju Just Like ilhan
Omar treats their country it's just an
instrument for one's personal interests
and and uh other loyalties and other
sympathies it's not good both the left
and the right have lost a conception of
the common good and and uh of of giving
of themselves to their Community to even
have a community to which they can be
loyal we deny that in our age of radical
individualism and and radical liberalism
and and but if you don't do that if you
don't give to your community then you're
not going to be able to construct
anything you're not going to be able to
build the only thing you're going to
leave to your children is an inheritance
of debt and a country in
rubble got to change that thinking right
now go to woke tear
water.com are you sick of companies
trying to turn you into a big lib seems
that wokeism is everywhere it's in the
air we breathe it's even in the water
that we drink that is why there is a new
hydration brand out there with a mission
to save America from the brave new woke
world one sip at a time woke tear water
is an American brand that is making
hydration great again woke water is a
legitimate brand of drinking water
bottled right here in the US OFA by
people who know what a woman is made
from Pure snowflake meltdowns woke tears
doesn't see color in fact the water
identifies as the most transparent in
the world while everyone else's water is
just water woke tears provides a
refreshing gulp of laughter in a world
thirsty for sanity not only will
drinking woke tears water keep you
hydrated but you will always have a
conversation starter as well if you want
to try woke Tew water you do obviously
go to woke Tew water.com indulge today
in laughter and hydration two of the
very most important things in life woke
tarwater
decom today an abortion Doula just gave
a lecture at the Catholic University of
America I was disinvited from a Catholic
university called the University of St
Thomas because I I don't believe in
I was just disinvited from the
University of St Thomas twice actually I
think uh because I believe in
Catholicism and Catholic teachings on
these questions the completely unchanged
consistent Catholic teaching of 2,000
years that's why they disinvited me and
now we have a Catholic University
inviting an abortion Doula what's an
abortion Doula an abortion Doula is like
a doula you know and adulla is just a
hippie term for a midwife Nanny you know
helper uh who will help help a woman as
she's giving birth to a baby and then in
the early days while the while the you
know newborn is is nice and fresh you
know and the mother's trying to sleep a
doula can help out then well an abortion
Doula is like that except for killing
the babies this abortion
Doula she spoke on her experiences
coaching coaching women through
delivering or aborting babies as well as
coaching pregnant men to deliver in what
she referred to as a seahorse birth uh
this is according to audio of the
lecture obtained by the daily signal she
also practices raiki which is an occult
practice that involves demons uh so she
does that Catholic University her name
is uh oh the woman who invited her
rather is Melissa Goldberg she is a
psychology lecturer at Catholic
University the du's name is Rachel
carbano sounds kind of voodoo and this
was for uh psychology 379 lifespan
development so one of the students a
nursing student named Filipe Avila said
it was really upsetting the fundamental
point is to understand human development
from conception to Natural death right
and they brought in someone who counsels
women to terminate life what's that
about it's
crazy it's actually destructive to their
you know if you go to Catholic
University you are supposed to be
receiving a Catholic
Education this contradicts the Catholic
Education this confuses the Catholic
Education bringing in this woman to
speak harms the the education of
students it it doesn't really help it at
all other than perhaps to expose them to
just
how radically depraved the culture has
become outside of uh Catholic
thinking but the Libertarians aren't
going to like my suggestion here that
maybe CUA should cancel these kinds of
people what what the question you got to
ask yourself is what's the point of
education is the point of Education to
just hear everything man just open your
mind up you know to totally to
everything look I am the most canceled
speaker in America of 2023 per the uh
foundation for individual rights and
education okay I'm I speak I know what
I'm talking about here
and I totally defend the right of
certain schools to exclude certain
speakers if if you send your kid to
communist Academy it's probably not a
good idea to invite me to speak there
you know the parents and the kids are
paying to be indoctrinated into
communism and to to have a a communist
ideology and I'm going to contradict
that probably not a not a great
idea now I I think I should still
probably go because communism is false
and there is such a thing as truth and
we can know about it and we should
prefer truth to
falsehood but that's what we're talking
about here I was talking to my friend
yuram honei the Israeli philosopher who
called my attention to a a phrase that
slipped into our culture that I think is
just so it didn't even occur to me how
bad this phrase is the phrase is
critical
thinking you know you hear it sometimes
Educators even on the right they'll say
we don't want to teach our students what
to think only how to think as if you
could do one without the other is as if
as if you could ever know how to think
without knowing specific things to think
you know 2 plus 2 equals 4 murder is bad
whatever but but he said this phrase
critical thinking why why do we have all
this critical thinking whatever happened
to constructive thinking constructive
thinking is when you learn a thing and
then you build on that then you build on
that you build on that and eventually
you have an edifice of knowledge before
you critical thinking just pokes holes
in everything seems related to critical
theory critical studies just debunking
and deconstructing and tearing
everything down to the point that by the
time you graduate you're dumber than
when you went in there there was a
survey it came out a while ago now I
think from isi 2007 that that showed
that students at Elite colleges in
America got Dumber the longer they
attended that that graduating seniors
knew less about history and Civics than
incoming freshmen that's critical
thinking for you that's deconstruction I
like constructive thinking and I like
Banning speakers who are harmful to
education man what a great clip that was
now hold up ring that Bell subscribe to
the Michael NS YouTube channel and we
will see
you next time